there's a lot about lumen
and what's going on that we don't know
about but the two of you play characters
who are working at a much higher level
within the company so i'm just curious
for the both of you and trammell i'd
love to start with you
how much were you clued in on in advance
and did you have the chance to ask
questions and kind of get some insider
information from dan
um about any secrets
oh absolutely um i knew very little and
very little um walking into this and dan
and ben were very instrumental in the
collaborative process and talking
through it but there were there were a
lot of secrets just like blumen has
secrets and so it took a lot of faith
you know
when it comes to those questions that
they could not answer
and this was definitely an exercise
where the character knew more than the
actor so i just had to go with it and uh
just take the leap
yeah there was i had so many questions
and some of them i got answered and a
lot of them didn't and then some that
got answered
led to a thousand more questions but
basically i think
we in upper management
in this corporation
it's taken a long time
and many many years of asking less and
less questions and understanding what
our boundaries are
and
leading first with you know
what the corporate rules are and what
the structure is
so by the time that we've already
arrived here there's already a lot of
ignoring your own inner questions
not listening to them not leading with
them not you know we've already been
kind of
trained like pavlov dogs at this point
to already just be moving forward even
if it doesn't make sense it doesn't
matter if it makes sense or not if this
is what we're supposed to be doing this
is what we're doing
but then there is this part of my
character that
is a little
outside the lines
and
for her own
uh
you know her own placement in this
company to earn something also to give
back to this corporation which is
not just like a corporation or it's
almost like a religion and a family and
everything all rolled into one
it's her whole childhood on up you know
this this
entity is so much a part of her life
the shadow of it looms so large
so
i don't know if that makes sense but
it's for sure layered
um the two of you play such a complex
relationship on the show was there
anything any surprises that happened
during filming that maybe added more
intricacy to the relationship that
wasn't necessarily on the page patricia
i'd love to start with you for that
um there's stuff that i think are
surprises that are on the page
um that were very surprising to me and
interesting
um
but a lot of it was actually editing
i think for
all of us
we would have like ideas or natural
instincts that would happen and part of
it was like no you can't do that
so you get kept getting put into this
confined space
so i actually saw a lot of different
colors
and choices tremel had
or even from myself that
got confined out
that was interesting to work in
confinement yeah no the um
i like that there it's that but i would
also i would add that one of the biggest
i won't say surprises the biggest
blessings was that patricia and i got
along so well
that we could vibe with each other and
laugh even in the midst of filming in
this tenuous situation with covet going
on you know
and which did not foster these really
bright relationships that we would often
have you know when we're on set but you
know patricia is so giving and so
friendly
and very open and so it was great to be
able to have that camaraderie together
um so much closer than i believe that
milcek and
cobell would have you know um because
you know milcheck looks up to cobell and
that's his mentor so that was it was a
great bonus to have that camaraderie um
it's so much fun to watch the two of you
in the show
i cannot wait for everyone else to see
it i have to wrap up but thank you so
much for taking the time to sit and talk
about this and
um and i am crossing my fingers very
hard that we get more of it i feel like
we scratch the surface of like what can
be uncovered
thank you so much thank you nice talking
to you